Here are seven dating tips.
First, you should not ask a woman if you could date her because women like men who are in control.
Second, you will also look insecure if you ask a woman about her previous relationships.
Third, a man should never try to impress a woman by boasting about his wealth.
She will be more impressed if money is not mentioned.
Four, women don't like to have to think about what to do on a date.
Men should have a plan, so don't ask her to come up with one.
Five, a man looks as if he lacks confidence if he asks a woman if she likes him.
It will put her off the man for sure.
In sixth place is, don't ask a woman why she has not answered your message.
It will make her feel guilty, which is not helpful.
And lastly, you should never ask a woman if you could kiss her, because you will look immature to her.